it's important as like a japanese voice
actor to be able to
you know do you have to audition for
animal roles i already had it in my
voice for you
guys can you do something yeah yeah yeah
i can do a cat as well
and welcome to another episode of trash
taste i am the host for today
gant and with me are as usual the boys
and as you can see i am not alone on
this side i am reclaiming
the host share as we have a guest on
would you like to introduce yourself to
the crowd
yes hi everyone my name is shu cheetah
and i'm a voice actor in japan
um yeah nice to meet you guys
as the viewership knows of course yeah
you know the five percent of time we
talk about anime
this is one of those five percent
exactly
actually yeah i think this might be the
like the official well first of all
you're the official first guest on the
new set
chris chris we're not counting chris
chris ain't a guest anymore this is this
is this is the first real guest episode
of
studio first real guest but also like i
think people have pointed out
in your accent or figured out from your
accent that you're australian yes i am
australian yeah
yeah and i'm australian too and i i
literally went to school
yeah so to explain off-screen uh we just
found out that these two went to the
same kind of school together
um and they know each other as like
childhood friends or something like that
so do you guys want to explain that what
happened with that well
um well like the japanese community in
australia like
the parents there send like their kids
to like this thing called saturday
school so we have school
on saturdays from around 10 to like 1pm
and then um yeah like we were in
different classes
because you were like in a higher grade
then yeah i think i'm two years older
than you
yeah yeah yeah so but i was in the same
class as
huss older sister right about seven
years
or something yeah and because like and
again because like the school is so
small because the community is so small
you
naturally hang out with kids who are
younger than you and older
so yeah like i would see shoe in like
the playground and stuff
it's like the meme where like every
asian knows each other but it's actually
true
every japanese person knows each other
yeah so like
yeah so not only did i go to i was in
the same class as her sister but like
yeah we used to like
hang out like everything not not too
often yeah not too often but
like we had so many mutual friends that
i think it's just like naturally we knew
each other okay
yeah so uh and now she's an anime voice
and now you both work in the anime
industry
yeah i gotta ask like in in this like
japanese community were there
many people who wanted to work in the
anime industry because you know how it
is with like the weeb culture he's like
you see an anime fan and they're like oh
i want to work an anime like all right
weeb all right
but like what was it like for like the
japanese community
i don't know i mean i think at that
point i
wasn't even really thinking about that
at all i'm too busy enjoying the weebles
yeah exactly so it's like i don't know
because i think even back then like i
knew i always wanted to like live and
work in japan
yeah but i think like the whole like
anime industry side of things was
just kind of like a dream yeah so
mystical no one knows anything well
that's the thing right it's like i
wouldn't
like back then i was like how do you
even like begin to try and get into an
industry like yeah right so it's like
you know if i end up working in it it's
like
cool but like it wasn't like i was
chasing the weeb dream
yeah i'm definitely gonna like work for
kyoto
well i work for studio when i'm older
yeah i was on that hustle since age two
to get in the anime industry
well it's like no but um i mean i don't
know did you
know anybody like what was it like for
you like did you always wanted to become
an anime voice actress for me i was like
i was like opposite to you and i was
like i really want to become a voice
actor and i'm going to become a voice oh
you're almost okay
yeah yeah okay and so um but i didn't
know anyone around me who
wanted to become like you know someone
who was in the anime industry so
like for me it was just me like come to
japan
to get into this industry because i
think the majority of like the people at
our saturday school weren't even really
like thinking to
be in japan yeah yeah because like even
to this day like most of my japanese
friends from that saturday school
most of them still live in sydney and
that's just like yeah
normal english-speaking everyday job
kind of thing so it's like
yeah i think shu and i are the weird
ones i mean i i already hear the word
saturday school and i'm like you guys
are crazy
my god five days of school was enough
for me one more day in the weekend nah
mother mother i am not attending another
school day okay
i fought like hell to get out of sunday
school yeah my biggest battle of life
i mean to be fair like i personally
didn't even see it as
like a school for me was more just like
a hangout to like hang out with like all
these tricks
they [ __ ] tricked you they sold you
on another day of school
i mean like again like it's it's not
like i didn't learn anything
right like obviously especially when you
get because the school we had it started
from kindergarten
so like what you're like four or five
years old all the way up until ninth
grade where you're
brainwashed indoctrinated i'm just
hearing indoctrination here
get them out get them all they're young
build a habit and they'll just they'll
love it
they'll learn to love it
i think obviously the viewers are
probably wondering what are some shows
that you've voiced in because that's
probably gonna be the first thing they
wanted oh yeah yeah
and then we could yeah and then we can
go yeah yeah i voice uh mia taylor from
love live school idol festival all-stars
i also voice uh war spite ark royal
perth uh mikura and gambia bay from
kankore
kantai collection kankore that's a big
collection right there
yeah and yeah and a lot more i'm i'm
like
i'm in like dry morn and you're into
raymond
yeah i think i think that's the true web
dream where it's like you're in a show
that is
literally your childhood exactly yeah
i'm also in like um xinjiang
oh you're in shock just a bit yeah yeah
sometimes
that's so cool like i mostly do like
dogs and cats
but yeah yeah i i um i mean like
like animes and games and stuff like
that so yeah awesome that's so cool yeah
i feel like you're downplaying it you
should be like i am in anime that's not
a thing
most people can say also i don't think
you realize that the literal hundreds
and thousands of people who watch our
show
who only dream to be in your position
exactly you're an actual real anime
voice actress that's like most people
dream to be that
i just want to point out because i know
the view is going to point out as well
how comically large
i look sitting next to you because i'm
seeing myself on screen and i'm like if
you thought you just
tuned into the newest season of attack
on thai tonight this is i assure you
this is trash taste it's literally the
meme of like
six feet versus especially especially on
that camera i look so comically large
so you mentioned that you wanted to be a
voice actor from a young age
when did that start then walk me through
the process i'm interested well
um like i started to i started liking
anime
um because my sister used to like anime
and then so i used to watch anime with
her and um
i wanted to become a voice actor when i
was in a primary school
oh very young very young i didn't even
know that was like a job when i was in
prime minister
yeah yeah i was just like funny acting
people i just thought the characters
just existed
goku's there somewhere in the world
right yeah yeah i'm sure he exists
yeah like um i was watching um bleach
with my sister
and you know yeah yeah voiced by um
she's like a woman and she's like voice
acting a a boy
yeah yeah and so i was really like
fascinated by that and i was like
oh i really want to become a voice actor
and then from then on i was kind of like
um i told my parents um that i wanted to
become a voice actor in japan and
you know like typical asian parents
they're like
um
[Applause]
what is a voice actor i've never heard
of that job before do you need a degree
to get it
and what was interesting was that um at
saturday school
uh i used to get like super low marks
like in my
test right so my parents were like well
like you're getting such low marks
in japanese like how are you like you
know gonna become a voice actor in japan
where it's like you know
you need to be really good at speaking
japanese yeah yeah
yeah yeah and then so um yeah my parents
were like against me but i was like i
want to become a voice actor in japan so
um yeah in high school i kind of um
started auditioning for like
um the schools or the voice acting
schools in um japan
oh wow oh okay what what i age in high
school
i think like 16 17.
wow so like i would like work part-time
and then i'll save money
and then i'll book a flight to japan oh
my god
yeah i was like i was like working like
like
four or five times a week and then like
on like
you know during school holidays i'll be
working like six times a week or like
you know
just when the holy [ __ ] you were really
on my grind yeah yeah i was like super
like i want to become
yeah and like um and um a lot of the
places uh told me that because i live
overseas it's kind of like
you know like yeah quite hard yeah yeah
but then
um i finally like passed the audition
and they're like you know please come to
um the school yeah and then so
um i decided to go to japan but um
at that time i was in i was still in uni
okay and
you know like my parents were like well
isn't it better if you kind of like
finish
uni and then yeah yeah
and so i was kind of like yeah maybe but
uh no
during my um during the holidays i like
worked more
and then i saved up a lot of money and
um you know in australia it's like when
you're
18 you can kind of decide everything
yeah yourself yeah so like
um i kind of quit uni
without telling my parents that's
i think that's like the worst thing you
can do right it's like number one no no
that's like that's like one step away
from a lot
holy [ __ ] i've never actually heard an
asian kid do that
i'm just like i'm just
i felt that in my soul man like a
thousand of
thousands of my ancestors just screamed
right there
is this what happens when an asian
unlocks like their final form
i feel like i just witnessed ultra
instinct irl man
jesus christ and then so um
um it doesn't stop there like i i like i
quit uni
and then um i didn't tell my parents and
then you're gonna quit uni like for a
while
or was it just kind of like [ __ ] it i'm
doing it well um before going to uni
i was gonna i wasn't really actually
gonna go to uni
but then my parents were like can you go
to uni
and then so i was like okay and then i
went to uni for one year and then
um yeah and um
wait so what was the question like did
you when you went into uni you're like
yeah i'm not gonna stick with this or
was it like you just had enough
[ __ ] japan yeah um i went to i went
to the um
the classes there and i was like not
like this
hell nah hell no
but i was like but i guess i did sign up
yeah and then so um i booked um the
flights to japan
um without telling my parents and
um i think around a week before the
flights
i told my parents that
to see you because my parents were so
against
me going oh yeah yeah yeah so um like a
week before
i told my parents and um by then i had
already like
um booked um the packaging what is it
like
the people who come to take your package
to send it to japan oh yeah
and so um yeah so they just like showed
up and they were like what what's all
this
what's all this thing so you literally
just sort out all the logistics
yeah and then oh my god one day before
like the package goes you're like mom
i'm leaving
btc by the way mom going to japan
you told them like boss music start
playing
well my i think my parents weren't
expecting me
to like act in that way because like
you know in school i was that girl that
was like you know i would like study a
lot and then
yeah yeah and then so when i told her
she was kind of like
okay just like top 10 anime betrayals in
real life
jesus yeah but then um like because 18
in australia is like you're considered
like an
adult but yeah teen in japan you're
still considered like
a child a child yeah you're right yeah
20 yeah
yeah and then so um i had booked the
flights to japan but i hadn't
um like rented any like house or like
anything
and i was like oh i could just stay in a
hotel until i can um like rent a house
but then
after going to japan i realized that you
couldn't book a house
like you couldn't rent a house when
you're like 18. so yeah yeah
oh you you need parents permission
because my parents were really against
me right they wouldn't they'll be like
and so um i went through all my contacts
and i contacted all my friends and i was
like is anyone in japan like you know
living in japan can i like
live with you like yeah yeah yeah and
then there was like one girl um
that went to the same school saturday
school and she used this this saturday
so we're paying off the evidence man
that's what that's what the torture is
i'm jealous and then um you know she
like
luckily she actually um had a bunk bed
in her room
and the reason why she had a bunch of
[ __ ] randomly well because um like her
parents would be coming over from
australia to
japan like once in a while she was like
oh i could just you know have like a
bunk bed so they could
sleep there when they come yeah and so
um yeah she was like well i have a bunk
bed and you know
if if you're fine with that then we can
live together so we lived together for a
while and then
i started going to the school there and
that's how it
all kind of started that's that's a
[ __ ] badass story man
holy [ __ ]
jesus christ that's literally like the
equivalent of like the
og american dream kind of story where
you just like you pack your bags you go
to like la or whatever and you just
figure it out and that's kind of what
you did it's literally like
i'm on a i'm on a quest to find myself
like that level right it's like parents
won't hold me back
i got this that's so cool i assume
obviously having native japanese is a
big plus
i've heard that in japan they're really
strict with like pronunciation and then
voice acting
like perfect yeah i still have problems
with my accent like
sometimes like yeah because like you
know like even for kanji there's like so
many ways of reading like the same kanji
and then like for accents it's like it's
like you know it also depends on the
sentence
like accent changes you know and so like
yeah i still have
i'm still like kind of learning my
accent right
yeah yeah i i'm getting used to it i
mean yeah i feel that like especially
i feel like just voice acting agencies
like anywhere in any country is like you
know quite high standards but i feel
japan especially has some
pretty insane standards oh because it's
one of the most sought-after jobs in
japan
right right yeah it's a huge competition
freddie
after youtube
all the kids in japan are like number
one youtuber number two voiceover
well i've you know you've seen loads of
videos about it and of like people going
into these schools and it's like a
military camp
and you feel so bad because you're like
all these people mostly people
have had their dreams crushed yeah
they're not gonna make it yeah like what
what is like the kind of
daily routine for uh
what what is like the daily routine for
like schools like that because like
you only hear about voice acting schools
in japan but like you know obviously i
don't think any of us have been doing it
or knowing
about it i mean it depends on the school
like some schools
um you have to go there like five times
a week um some school they only have it
like
once a week and i went to one that was
only like once a week
and the teachers there will be really um
strict
and um in japanese you call it like
taika kaike it's really like
they're really strict yeah right yeah so
like um
we do like um you know accent and
pronunciation and we also do like um
what is it in english like
oh like uh so that it's like you know to
fix like lisps
yeah yeah yeah so like be able to
pronounce like all syllables
yeah yeah yeah i don't know what it's
called i don't know pronunciation right
yeah pronunciation i guess
enunciation enunciation pronunciations
very very important part yeah people
overlook
but then um because the teachers were
like really strict like
um by like six months into starting
school
like half of the students wouldn't would
start not coming to school
right right just kind of like
disappearing
disappear right right kind of like uni
then
so is it like kind of a strict process
for even getting into this school like
you mentioned you have to audition a
bunch in your turn
yeah um this also depends on the school
like some schools are really strict um
some schools um they're not as strict
because like you know you you learn
everything at school so like
you know i think they're looking for
like people with like nice voices or
like you know
okay people who have like potential kick
anyone out there like you know you're
terrible go home
um like all the auditions like
kind of like that i guess yeah well it's
kind of like
it comes through post like whether you
passed or not so it's like
oh yeah they want to tell you in person
like you go to the audition and they're
like okay thank you like you know and
you go home and then like a week later
that's just such typical like
passive-aggressive japanese yeah yeah
you're terrible goodbye exactly so how
long would you typically study at the
voice acting school
um i went to uh the voice acting school
for two years some people only go for
like
a year as well you don't get any jobs in
that time it's pure like
purely just um well uh for me
it was i got a job when i was at school
yeah
and um that was only because i was able
to speak english
not really common yeah right yeah i
guess you have the the advantage of
being bilingual yeah so you get like
that
you get those english jobs yeah yeah
yeah yeah i'm just talking to kind of
how like being bilingual
in this country or in any asian country
if you want a job in that country it's
just like so easy
it's like a cheat code almost i mean i
mean that's you know one of the big
reasons why i wanted to move here right
is because like
you know in australia no one really
gives a [ __ ] if you can speak japanese
yeah the only job you'd probably be able
to get is like
teaching japanese like the saturday
school year yeah
but it's like even then it's like a lot
of japanese teachers
in australia don't even really speak
that
good of japanese yeah in an alternative
timeline you were an interpreter for the
president
of this that's probably the only one
i was talking to like the president of
the prime minister of japan you just
chose behind him like
telling him in the year like the only
like real
high-end job you could probably get yeah
japanese but like here for example like
every company in every field is looking
for someone to speak english yeah so
it's just
natural progression to just come here
yeah exactly
what i want to know is like the things
you learn in voice acting school do they
specifically teach you how to sound like
an
anime character because like because
like i've noticed obviously as
it's common sense that you know anime
characters sound very different from how
people usually speak right yeah
so do you what goes into like learning
how to speak like that
uh this also depends on like which kind
of teacher you have but some teachers
are based like
on like acting so they're more like
instead of like you know
sounding like an anime character like
they want you to focus on your acting
skills
but some like teachers actually do like
tell you like you need to be more like
like over like over the top yeah yeah
you know because like anime characters
they're like over the top
so like yeah yeah so yeah okay so you've
been in school for two years
how does it then transition into being
like you're a professional now start
working like what
is that is it like a set end date at the
school or is it like
they just they're like you're ready now
kid go on start
for my school uh there was like a set
date that um you finished school
and before you finish school you'll have
like auditions to get into
um the agency yeah
[Music]
yeah they'll be like you know um staff
they're like looking at you and
yeah usually you'll be handed like a
script like 15 minutes before you
actually um
act in front of the ultra people
and so what is the point of that because
it's like
that doesn't happen on a regular journey
like you don't show up to the studio not
knowing what enemy you're going to be in
and being like
here's the script uh you're recording
into it it's really common at least in
english that you wouldn't know
you wouldn't see the script until you're
actually recording it though yeah but in
japan
i mean like for like narration or like
sometimes there's like times when they
give it to you on
on that day yeah well like in regards to
like anime and games it's more like you
know you get like
like several days yeah because the free
planning stage for anime and games
is insanely wonderful because there's
sometimes in english that's still
changing the lines
while you're getting
they might change them or like maybe you
know they'll change it while you're
doing the lines
yeah yeah before you guys like i don't
like this anymore i want to change it
i'm like okay
yeah because when i because when i did
the stuff for uh pop team epic
they gave me the script like like four
weeks before i actually went in yeah
so no nda either right huh no nda either
oh nda
they gave me i talked about the podcast
but they literally gave me a cd
of the episode oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
like is that just like a common thing
yeah it's like a like
like anime recordings right yeah yeah
yeah yeah you get like a cd beforehand
and you check that at home and then you
see how long you're
like and then you kind of like check out
the timing of like when to start do you
have to like sign anything saying i
won't show this to anyone
no what did the trust system here dude
yeah that's crazy this video is
sponsored by crunchyroll crunchyroll
just kicked off a new slate of anime for
the summer season not only will the
service host continuing classics like
boruto my hero academia and one piece
but this season is
stacked with the return of popular
series like miss versus dragon made
s tokyo revenges to your eternity and
that time i got reincarnated
as a slime and don't forget you can
binge watch all the episodes of the
incredible odd taxi
right now i've already talked about it
many times but if you're looking for
another show
i highly recommend the second season of
that time i got reincarnated as a slime
season two is popping off and you need
to watch it right now
way to plug your own video but guys shut
up did you know there's new titles
airing this season
no way you won't believe it some of the
top picks include peach boy riverside
the great jahi will not be defeated i
love that one and fina pirate princess
and the new trailer just dropped you can
watch all these titles for free or try a
14-day free trial of premium membership
to skip all the ads and access
simulcasting with japan
just follow the link in the description
to start watching crunchyroll
now and the guest that we have on today
voices in some of the titles that you
can find on crunchyroll just follow the
link in the description below
to start watching on crunchyroll back to
the episode so how did you feel
getting your first role or how how was
that feeling when you were just like
man i'm actually like achieving my dream
right now
well um we had an audition to get that
role
and um i knew that it was like like
an english-speaking character like the
audition was like you had to speak in
english
right like just anything in english and
so um
yeah there was like other people um that
were like auditioning as well
and i was like i'm the one that's like
that can talk english
excuse me are you ego josue i don't
think so
i don't think so i was like oh if i
don't get this role i'm gonna like maybe
this is not like
yeah like when i heard that i got the
role i was like super happy because
obviously not many people who are still
in school get
a job yeah yeah um and you know a lot of
people
um even after they like graduate they
don't get
you know jobs right yeah so just like
normal university
and so yeah i was like i was super happy
because i
like you know because my first job was
conquered like contact collection
and that was like a huge game as well so
yeah i was just my first job is kankure
like
oh like oh my god yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's so cool
i mean did you like parents find out
about it too like did you tell them or
i told them but um they're they're
they're not really like into anime
and stuff so they're like oh really
that's nice
enjoy walleye yeah yeah yeah yeah wait
so how do parents feel about what you do
now then
um well um now they're um they're like
more accepting and they're kind of like
you know
yeah yeah because they're starting to
see like yeah yeah yeah results yeah
when you get a stable income parents are
always like all right
maybe this isn't too bad
yeah that's literally almost like for my
parents as well because like when i was
still doing it at home
during uni the whole youtube thing they
were like you have fun with that while
last you know it's like it's
that's a good pain you got there and
then when my dad was like
you make more than i do her mom that's
when he was finally like
like do your parents know kind of what
you do now do they understand at least
what you do
yeah like um uh my sister she she
she kind of she kind of shows like what
i do to my parents
right so like um yeah they they kind of
now
know what that's good do they do that
thing where like wait this is you
yeah they don't believe it they're like
like i remember when i first like tried
to explain what my job to my parents
were like
what are you how would you make money
off this i don't understand this youtube
thing
and then like cut to like three years
later my dad like phones me up and being
like
uh i was checking your social blade and
your last video seems to be
underperformed there you go
like what's going on with that
it's a transition from not knowing
anything
like anything to suddenly be like an
analyst right
i'm like you you you gained a hundred
less subscribers than on average for
this day
what's going on are you are you paying
enough attention that's like still cute
though yeah because like my parents are
definitely not that
like i think my parents are kind of they
went from not knowing or caring
to kind of being like caring but still
not really knowing
you know like i think when i ask my dad
like
what he thinks about what i do for a job
he was just like
oh you know i don't support it i just
let you do it
i guess it's really hard to explain to
your parents like what
kind of job it is true true yeah i guess
for a voice actor you can just say i'm
an actor
you can just show them a clip and be
like that me yeah
my grandma to this day still thinks i'm
a comedian
because that's the only way i can
explain it to my grandma who's like hey
your grandson is a comedian that's just
not on tv and she's like
oh wow okay very good sweet i gotta ask
going back to like the saturday school
thing in the small community
i gotta ask did all your parents know
each other as well
is that is that an asian thing or i mean
i think a lot of the parents
did know each other but i think that was
only really
like if you kind of grew up with that
kid
right from a really really young right
because like we had a lot of like
uh childhood friends right yeah um that
i would grow up with that
eventually you know would like do the
same sports activities or do the same
you know or go to the same saturday
school yeah go to the same primary or
yes or whatever but like
i didn't really know her sister
or her or shoe all that much yeah to the
point where our parents knew each other
like yeah yeah we had mutual like parent
friends yeah yeah yeah yeah
but yeah i don't think it ever got to
that one yeah because i i just asked
because i obviously didn't go to sunday
school but this this is how
it's saturday school saturday i'm sorry
i'm sorry
i don't pray we don't pray it's the week
it's weekend school i'm just gonna call
it weekend
[Laughter]
let me tell you how socializing worked
in like the entire community when i was
growing up
we didn't have weekend school right um
so like
every every thai parent would for some
reason know each other within like a
[ __ ] 50 mile radius
and they'd hang out and they were like
your kid your kid you're
you're like within the same age
socialize and now
make friends yeah right yeah and that
was basically how i knew
all the kids in like my area and
is it the same in japan as well where
you refer to each other as like kind of
like
kind of like brother or sister or like
cousins
very much a southeast asian okay okay so
it was really confusing
uh explaining this to sydney because i
would i would introduce sydney to like a
family friend yeah
but i would introduce them as a cousin
yeah and i would
introduce my actual cousins as cousins
so southeast asian like family trees are
just a [ __ ] mess because we call
everyone brother sister or cousins
everyone's family okay any of these
discussions
this is not me so like when you like
refer to your
cousins right yeah do you say like the
cousin that's not
in that's not like yeah yeah no there's
no distinction we just call them cousin
cousin
and then i have to and then sydney's
just like so whenever i introduce a new
cousin so she's just like
is this a cousin cousin or just a cousin
i'm just like it's a it's a real cousin
but they're all real
white people equivalent of calling
everyone your uncle or aunt i guess
oh this is your uncle and i found out
they weren't my uncle and i was like
what
why did you lie i mean yeah like my
australian side definitely had that
where like my dad's friends would be my
uncles or like you know my
you know but i don't think japanese
don't really do that no i don't think so
yeah yeah i feel because like
in japan especially like the concept of
family is very much like closed off in a
lot of sense
like you really have to be like part of
the family in order to be considered a
family member
yeah it's not it's not like an italian
like hey brother
there's not anything like that right all
like the whole cousin theme yeah cause
like
i just can't get over i mean just held
up a signature said incest
oh is that where god's obsession for
[ __ ] sake
okay anyway no but like no taken
off guard by that who just holds up a
sign that's his incest what
guys are it's the incest cube
the japanese side really had that like
it was like it was like it's a
it's a childhood friend and that's like
the extent yeah okay
but i feel like yeah definitely like you
know it's it's not like we couldn't make
friends later on in life but i feel like
a lot of the friends you did make
especially in sydney with the japanese
community a lot of it was very heavily
rooted in like
how oh you know how long have you known
this person for
you know kind of thing is that why there
are so many childhood friend characters
in anime yeah
i just got to ask them in real life
i was the one thinking about it i mean
like you know like if you're friends
since like like four when you're like
like
four years of age you're like you stay
friends for like forever
yeah kind of thing yeah yeah i did get
that about like japanese culture it's
it's like i got the impression that you
know it's
you there's like different levels of
friendship within japanese culture and
it's very hard to like penetrate like
the deeper level unless you've known
them for like a very very long time
i don't know okay
thank you very much no
it's like rooted in reality because you
know a lot of
my japanese friends to this day in from
australia
are guys and girls i've known since i
was you know like less than one year old
right
or like um less than one year old
because like at least with my mom how i
got to know a lot of them was that
because again like the japanese
community was so smart
yeah it the moms would go to like these
like mom friend groups
where like moms of that had kids of
similar ages right would come together
and so like naturally you you know
at like the age of like six months to
anyone pops out the vagina it's like
son let me introduce you to your best
friend
why are you saying
what's going on today
i don't like dead ass like i pop out the
bag before i see my own father
he's your best friend it's like that one
but like
my my my oldest friend my oldest
childhood friend to this day who's also
half japanese half australian who lives
here now
i met before i could even walk so like
it's
crazy to think that i'm 26 now and i've
dead i've known him for
26 years of my life yeah so literally
when you say you've i've known him my
entire life yeah
so you feel quite strongly then towards
someone even if you don't speak to them
even if just because you grew up with
them
i i feel it's like one of those like
concepts of like you know it's the type
of friends where you're like
i don't have to text you every day to
know that i'm your friend right yeah
yeah because i mean it's more like oh
cool how you doing
yeah yeah yeah but it's one of those
friends where you're like you know you
don't text for a year or something
but you can casually still be like so
we're going to dinner yeah all right i
think if
my friend messaged me and was like i
haven't spoke to them in like years and
they were like hey can i can i stay at
your place for x
amount of time if it's like one day i'm
like i guess
but if everybody spoke to them like what
are they crazy
what if they've gone through things you
know like
what they just don't leave i feel that
like you would know about that in some
way right especially because like for us
the parents were also involved
yeah that's true so it's like i know my
friends like my childhood friends
parents just as well as you know i know
the friend right because it's it's kind
of like
i guess that's the only like whole
auntie and uncle or like cousin aspect
to where yeah
your childhood parents oh sorry your
childhood friend's parents
yeah are kind of like your uncle or your
aunt in a little aspect yeah
was that the same for you as well for me
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's like can't
relate
now now that i think about it and talk
about it it's a really weird concept you
can have just friends for just like for
free
yeah for free it's almost no work put in
just born no payroll it's almost like an
arranged friendship you know
like your parents both agree yes our
children can be friends right honestly
it is pretty much like
the only thing i get from my childhood
friends are just [ __ ] farmville
invites on facebook we're just driving
up the wall like [ __ ] off
well because like a lot of and i feel as
well like how strong of a bond you form
with your childhood friend
depends on how close you are or like the
same types of activities that you did
growing up or like
did you go also go to that [ __ ]
swimming school
in sydney um i was about to but the one
in kalani
my parents were like oh it's too far
away and so we didn't go oh really yeah
yeah so because there was this one like
swimming school that like
all the asians would go to yeah and
that's how that's also how like i kind
of
rekindled with a lot of like my
childhood friends that i met when i was
a baby
because like it was like oh the the
parent that i met during this like mom
circle yeah also takes their kids to the
swimming school
and i've been thinking to take my son or
daughter to the swimming school so i'll
just go to the same one that i know all
the parents at
so that's like so again like i feel like
that community is
so bonded tightly that like it'd be like
oh if
that parent is doing this thing i'll
send my kids there yeah you could say
your family
vin diesel q q q fast and furious
which might be dead by the time it comes
out by the time this comes out probably
like very outdated yeah exactly i'm
curious
obviously you mentioned that you were
very passionate about it from a young
age um but
obviously when you're not in school
before that there's only so many ways
you can i guess
practice or get experience and what did
you do before that
practice because i was just doing it
from my bedroom
i was like yeah yeah so like i i bought
like a really
that shitty microphone and then um
you know at home i'll be recording my
own voice and like hearing it again and
then recording it again
and you know because like now like voice
acting you have to be able to like sing
well as well
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah what like um
you have to i'm [ __ ] yeah like you
have to like dance as well right
so like voice voice actresses especially
yeah voice actors and actresses at this
day and age are basically idols wow it's
like totally different in like the west
yeah yeah like you know you have to like
like you're in magazines like you have
to look good
like you know like visually well i guess
that's why like again it's so
the competition is so intense yeah yeah
like you said the more idols but
you're they're always on tv right yeah
and so
yeah like you know in australia they
don't have much karaokes
no like yeah and so um there was one
really like crappy characters but it was
the closest thing we got to like the
japanese
style because like karaoke in australia
is a lot like in america where it's like
all open-minded yeah and yeah yeah
that i i've that's always been weird to
me that's not karaoke
when someone just god awful starts
because i'm like that guy's great that
guy went up there knowing he'd watch you
this song
no but like what if the opposite happens
right what if like the person before you
sings
like [ __ ] amazingly and then you're
like oh [ __ ] i have to go up and do sexy
back
yeah let me let me go let me do it
like if i'm gonna embarrass myself i
just at least i could just embarrass
myself in front of my friends yeah right
yeah yeah that's that's the way i think
about it
um yeah that's what that's why like the
concept of going to karaoke sober
is just non-existent in western
countries right because you're not going
to go out
up and sing on stage in front of
strangers if you're not intoxicated
unless you're just an amazing singer
yeah so what so you you had to learn how
to sing as well or
you already sang well i i i practiced
singing from my bedroom
yeah yeah but that was really
embarrassing because um because my
parents were against me
doing voice acting right
they'll be kind of like oh yeah you can
go sing in your room but obviously
because it's not like soundproof or
anything
like i'm like yeah my really bad singing
is like
like resonating throughout the whole
like house so like
you're practicing dancing as well when
you were like teenager no
like uh i didn't really practice dancing
because i was more into like
singing and acting right but yeah i'm
not much for dancing myself either
yeah it's really hard
yeah so with the voice acting school did
they teach you any of these other
aspects of being a voice actress or was
it just
purely the voice part uh the school that
i went to was like
just purely voice acting but i know like
um some schools teach you singing and
um dancing as well like especially like
you know how like i said that there was
like schools where you have to go like
five times a week yeah
yeah those five times like eight hours a
day or like i'm not really
sure but um i assume not like you
have to live somewhere i think i when i
watched a video about it it sounded like
they just go in the evening after their
job
like a lot of people do that in japan i
think that's normal that sounds about
right yeah there's like a lot of
different like
you know it always depends on the truth
like you know but um
yeah so some schools teaching so what
type of voice acting were you doing in
your bedroom when you were like 15 60.
um well i was kind of like copying
characters
you know like i feel it always starts
with like impersonating yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
dubs and stuff yeah yeah who did you
impersonate
[Laughter]
i i impersonated a lot um
um wait um let me just think who did you
impersonate
other than the obvious ones league of
legend characters yeah do you know how i
know that
because that's what he sent in for my
audition real there you go league of
legends
legends characters audition real oh my
god
i don't know i just copied everything i
don't and i would do weird stuff for
people who wanted
free you know because someone has to
voice out in these terrible stuff online
yeah
yeah yeah like sims projects and stuff
people just make sims animations and i
would just
you would have to do the voice i hated
it but i was like well i just i want a
voice act but i don't like the project
50 bucks is 50 bucks right yeah oh you
get paid are you kidding me no i know i
got paid
i was using a like a headset microphone
it sounded like
it's terrible but you know you love
doing it so you just you just
yeah until you can buy a good microphone
and
then you're like google how do i remove
static loud static how to remove
yeah your dasty
noise cancelling function it doesn't
work
yeah cause like uh back when i was like
like newly into the anime community
like what there was a big like online
voice acting community when i was first
going to the anime community was that
still a thing when you were trying to be
a voice actress
um no i don't think so really so yeah
does japan not have like a
an online scene for voice acting are
they just voice acting stuff online
i think um i think some people do like
voice act online
and um some people actually like voice
act on nico nicole
yeah yeah yeah and um but i
didn't really participate in that
because i was kind of like
oh like well when i was in australia my
japanese wasn't
as fluent right like it was really like
it sounded like
an australian was talking about yeah
yeah i get that
and so i was like oh like you know i
don't have much confidence so
i kind of practiced more from home okay
um yeah i was like
i was copying um
nice yeah and like you know all this
kind of practice
i was practicing animals too like
so you try to get the animal roles as
well
i just imagine animals you're shouting
at a doctor
yeah like because on the internet
they're like you know it's important as
like a japanese
voice actor to be able to you know do
you have to audition for animal roles
um uh for me it was kind of like
um i already had it in my voice reel
and so yeah they picked me from there
but what kind of animals like just dogs
like dogs cats yeah i guess that's the
majority right yeah
i'm so curious what was your what was
your process and like practicing for
that
i'll just like endlessly watch animals
on youtube
and then i'll kind of like copy the
animal um yeah and that was there's
there's people who have demo reels for
like uh
monster creature demo reel oh yeah
monster noises yeah like
weird sounds that human bodies shouldn't
make yes i guess someone's gonna voice
them right yeah yeah yeah exactly
there's i mean there's quite a bit
demand for that like there's always [ __ ]
that needs
rowling can you can you do something
yeah yeah um a dog
[Music]
a cat that's pretty funny that's really
good that's really good well if we
i mean if we said it was [ __ ] yeah
that sounds like a cat well just in your
passive aggressive letter later
it wasn't it wasn't very good you'll
receive a letter your phone yeah i
wonder if there's like any viewers
watching right now who has a cat in the
background who just like
yeah right about who's throwing hands
who's throwing hands the dog is just
losing it
that's so cool this video is sponsored
by manscaped the sun's out bombs are out
and hopefully your pubes are not out
also flip-flop season is upon us and
you're out here with those post-pandemic
toenails don't worry our friends of
manscape have you covered they just
launched their fourth generation
performance package and their shears tm
2.0
nail grooming kit join the manscape
movement by going to manscape.com for 20
off
plus free shipping i was this close
gentleman to
making uh my balls no more but that
could have been avoided if i had
manscaped that one time
when i was younger but thank god i can
buy it now the performance package 4.0
includes the new lawnmower 4.0
this trimmer will change the way you
approach your grooming routine
texas don't worry if that power goes out
again you can still use the lawnmower
4.0
because it's powered by batteries and
has its own led one of the most
important aspects is that this trimmer
is waterproof so you can trim in the
shower
with these i'm going to say that this is
so dramatic so get 20
off plus free shipping by going to
manscape.com slash trash taste that's 20
off plus free shipping at manscape.com
taste tame the summer swamp in your
pants with manscaped tm back to the
episode
your balls will thank you so i i'm
assuming it's going to be different but
what is the process
like in voice acting in japan for
auditioning
um for auditions uh will the auditions
come to your agency
and then the agency will um pick someone
that's suitable for the role
and they'll be like um there's like uh
two stages there's like tape
audition and there's a studio audition
um
and tape audition is where you just send
your voice into the people who make the
anime
and um stage audition is when they when
you actually go in front of all the
directors and
like the people who make the enemy if
that's okay
yeah so how many people will be there
normally uh depends on
like the anime but um
i don't know like sometimes there's like
only like twenty
five twenty like five ten twenty only
twenty
what sometimes there's like more there's
like yeah
wait this is this is the stuff right
yeah yeah yeah yeah twenty staff members
oh no no no no no no oh oh you mean
yeah sorry oh i was gonna say i was like
um staff members it depends but
sometimes
it's like the artist is staying here
she's got a good voice
it's not gonna match the grass but
sometimes like
there's like around usually there's
around five people
but sometimes they could be like 10 or
like maybe even more
wow like judging and like judging it wow
and then
there's about 20 to 30 auditioning uh
yeah for one character or
yeah sometimes for one character like
sometimes um
the anime like people they'll take like
a whole day auditioning like several
characters
and um like this was like pre-covered
yeah yeah yeah yeah but um yeah they'll
be like you know
they'll always be like people waiting in
the waiting room
and then oh god you're all like oh yeah
you go for the park
before you walk in just it's like
because they're holding the scripts
right and they're kind of like
practicing it in there
is that like big tension in the room
yeah there is like it's like super quiet
oh
that's so nerve-wracking and you see
someone holding the same script as you
are and you're like
you know because there's like people at
movies like i'm gonna like people who
turn up really cocky
yeah anyone ever like that who's like
i've got this go home ah
no because you know like even even like
the really like famous voice actors they
auditioned to get like
the same like the roles you might turn
up and they might be like a triple
a like yeah oh my god that's terrifying
but the good thing about this job is
that it's not always
them that get the job right it's like
the person who suits the voice
like the character best so yeah it is
really nerve-wracking though when
they're like in front of you and they're
like practicing their script and you're
like
oh wait so you've been in a situation
where you were in like auditioning for
the same role as a massive
boys
you know and it's like it's so
nerve-wracking just to like act in front
of like all the staff members making the
anime
and then there's like this huge like you
know someone you've known
like since like ages ago and yeah you're
probably a fan of yeah
yeah like who've like you've had like
posters of them up on your room or
something like that right yeah so
yeah it's like really nerve-wracking and
yeah that's like so different from how
they do it in like the
english anime because because they when
they're dubbed they have to be dubbed
like pretty fast
right so they can't like they never hold
open auditions it's been
it's been a very very long time i think
they'll be like hey
we we know that you're good at what you
do trying for this character you should
record an audio clip and send it in and
that's it
there's no like another one sometimes
there is but it really depends on the
thing
but it's really fast and it's that's why
there's normally like less actors i
guess compared to japan because
it's normally you have to be kind of
established to get a chance it's kind of
difficult
yeah wow how many auditions do you have
to go through or like for different
series before you normally land like a
single role
um uh well in the industry they say
like auditions like it's like
like it's like normal to like not pass
an audition so like
they say like if you like take 50
auditions if you get into one then
that's like
like you're you're still on the good
side like
40 to one yeah yeah yeah i suppose if
you're
like competing against 20 other voice
actresses yeah you know some people
spend all day from the home just on like
voices.com sending in like [ __ ]
hundreds
right drives me insane okay and yeah
it's really like
um like because like you know when you
get the audition you want to know more
about the character
and yeah you want to know more about the
um the manga or like you know whatever
it's based on so
like you you read all these manga and
like you know you take your time like
you know
understanding the character and stuff
like that and so yeah it's like
you know when you don't pass it's like
oh i didn't like yes sometimes i try not
to get too invested
because i feel that if i read the manga
i feel like i know this character i can
do it
why didn't i get it and then you gotta
go to the next one it's like yeah it
must be quite difficult
yeah how do you how do you kind of keep
that detachment level there
well at first i was like i felt really
like down when i didn't pass
yeah but then now it's kind of like like
you know you need to
take like you just keep like dropping
like you know
not understandable yeah yeah yeah yeah
you just you just gotta like you
grow thick skin i suppose yeah yeah and
just like it's nothing personal right
yeah nothing personal kid
so you mentioned obviously that's not
the normal process right now because of
kovid
is how is it different now because of
code um well um they used to
you know how i said that they used to
like uh call in people for auditions
now it's more like um you know uh you
have the tape auditions
and you get chosen from there or um they
choose someone
they're like they don't have auditions
at all and it's kind of like
they already choose someone to oh it's
like we want you to voice this character
yeah
yeah
kind of thing yeah would you have to
send another tape still um
it depends on the um oh so they're just
they're just scouting now then
yeah sometimes they just scout you
sometimes you have auditions
and um when they do have studio
auditions it's more like um you're
brought in one by one
yeah so it's like you know um so there's
no like that's there's no standard yeah
yeah yeah i feel that's better for like
mental health for voice actors
but that normally doesn't give a lot of
chance for i guess new talent to trust
yeah
yeah get seen because you i mean that's
how they get seen right yeah yeah
if you're if you have to be established
or scouted it's quite difficult to get
seen
yeah like how do how does that work for
like the english side of things because
like it sounds
[ __ ] impossible for like new talents
to get yeah
i mean you have normally have to be
recommended like someone be like you
know it's just who you know kind of
thing
i mean it's sad but yeah kind of i mean
you know there is ways but normally it
is
through recommendations and someone will
be like hey
i need this kind of voice does anyone
know someone who can do this so like
i got recommended to stuff just because
they were like we need british
and because obviously since kovid a lot
of a lot of anime dubs now the ones that
are
airing like weeks after are done all
online
oh wow really there's a quite a few
actually have been done just from home
studios so they just record
wow wow you have to have like a good
internet connection and you have to have
a sound treated room
right which i think when covered hit a
lot of the the bigger and more
established voice actors just you can
order those like
they have them in japan as well the home
office booths oh one of those things
it's like a tiny it's horrible because
it gets so hot and you can't have the ac
on them yeah
you're in this tiny room you're like
sweating on a call and you sometimes if
you're screaming it's like terrible
yeah yeah so yeah a lot of it now
especially
now it's quite bad for like
discoverability yeah you
kind of have to recommendations yeah uh
but yeah
you can you can audition for stuff still
but again to get the auditions you have
to be recommended
yeah it's about who you know i guess
yeah yeah i'm tough
so in in japan to even be considered for
an audition
uh i i do you have to have formal
training or they won't allow you um no
not necessarily it's like
um most of the time you have to be in an
agency yeah
so like just like to get into the agency
they like you know obviously they look
at people who
have like good acting skills right so
yeah um people in an agency would like
have like the you know the basic acting
skills
yeah from yeah the agent won't sign you
right
i guess we can get you work and then so
um yeah like the manager picks like who
they want to
um manage yeah like
yeah because the manager picks like who
they want to put forward for the
audition yeah they'll be like hey we
need these voices okay i think these
guys are good
take them yeah yeah yeah so like what's
what's the daily life of like a [ __ ] a
japanese voice actress and like do you
do more roles than auditions or like
how's the balance going
ah it's like it's like you do auditions
too but
like once you start getting the hang of
your job it's kind of like you have like
uh recordings for like uh you know games
and
other stuff that you did from like a
while ago so just like continuous
recordings and stuff like that
and so yeah it's like you do auditions
but at the same time you have like
engineers yeah so once you establish
yourself it's a lot easier because yeah
you've got a lot more stuff going on
there yeah yeah okay
okay how was it like uh cause i've done
the whole
it's called afriko in japanese but like
the recording session
uh i guess there's like one massive
difference between the west and japan is
that in the west it's you know one at a
time
yeah yeah yeah whereas in japan it's all
together all at once right yeah and like
like you've probably done it next to
some pretty
notable people yeah yeah it's pretty
crazy like um
well it's really nerve-wracking because
like you know um
you know like like now they record it a
little bit differently
but before they used to have like 30
people or 20 to 30 30 people in like a
room
in a studio and you'll be kind of
recording the anime at the same time
and so they'll usually be like four
microphones and
you know all the actors will be like
using that microphone like between each
other
yeah and so obviously um if like
someone who's bigger than you like your
senpai is using like a mic you can't
like barge in and like you know is that
mine
so like you know you have to like look
out for your senpai's as well
and you have to like act properly as
well and you know
sounds so stressful yeah i just want to
work you know
a bunch of like super established voice
actors are doing it because like there's
i think this is like really famous
youtube video of like
all the main uh voice actors for one
piece yeah doing a scene where all
of the straw hat crew is like talking in
a scene yeah and they're just so
fluidly like switching between
microphones when they're like rolls come
up and stuff because like
what i did as well is that like just
because you're not on the microphone it
doesn't mean you're not
acting because a lot of the times people
who aren't on the microphone
are used for like crowd noises all right
just passes by and stuff like that and
it's like
so you're constantly just like being
ridiculous
right as well when you're trying to act
to have like someone kind of providing
the feel of the scene to you you know
yeah i feel like that's why connoisseur
especially worked really well because
you hear like you you hear the original
like japanese dub of it
and it it kind of like you can tell that
the actresses and actors are just
bouncing off each other
really naturally and it's like hard to
tell it's actually
it's actually some points where it's
hard to tell if it's actually scripted
or just like completely
um improvised sometimes yeah they used
to do a lot more
for english productions but you know
scheduling is a nightmare
yeah yeah yeah yeah and for stuff like
you know like a disney movie if you have
like all these triple a
actors yeah impossible to get them all
at the same room at the same time
but some some movies and some shows
still do it um
but it used to be a lot more common but
now it's not really it's not yeah
because i've seen like footage of like
like toy story and stuff like that like
all the actors for toy story were all in
the same room like kind of in a semi
circle and they all just had like a mic
and
like a stand for their scriptures
it's normally the more expensive the
production the more you can do
that yeah if you have more money and you
can tell hey come in oh
you know for movies they'll always do a
like a table read right
the actors will come in and they'll just
practice it together even if they're not
recording together yeah
stuff like that the scary thing is
because like you know um once the anime
recording starts it's like
you have to like stay silent even when
it's not like your turn to speak so
like um even when you're reading the
script and you know it's not your turn
and
you want to like turn the page over you
have to be really
and like um when you walk up to the
microphone you can't make any sound so
like
you know even with your clothing it has
to be something that doesn't make sound
so like you know yeah you can't be
wearing like leather jackets and like
you know
stuff like that just like hello
they used to have like a box just full
of like really old t-shirts
really all the studios i worked at and
they were just like if you if you wore
anything that wasn't a t-shirt they like
put the t-shirt on
wow that doesn't sound sanitary it was
just wearing someone's sweaty t-shirt
right wash them
but it was just like they were like
don't don't bring anything that isn't a
t-shirt because it makes too much noise
yeah yeah and i don't have keys in your
pocket or anything like that
like just empty your pockets because i
hate to be the guy who just like came on
and i was like
[ __ ] i need to sneeze right now
and i feel that like the pressure is
even greater because it's like if you
[ __ ] up a line for instance
yeah then all the actors are there
so what happens if someone flops that
line well that happens um because
we're recording like you know like i
think i think we record like
each 15 minutes of an anime so like um
if you like mess up your line you just
stay silent and just
back away have you ever done that
i i could see like the ptsd in her face
as she was like telling the story i was
like oh she's experienced this
it's like um if you mess up you can't
see like oops or anything like that you
just have to like
stay silent so the person after you can
say their lines
and so like once so they can just like
cut your paper yeah and then they can
make sense take it again after the whole
15 minutes is like
recorded right so yeah and it's really
uh
it's really hard because when you first
start voice acting right
the director tells you like you know we
want that line said
more like this way or like you know in a
different way to what you did
and if you're not like able to like
you know say it like how the director
wants you to say it you like take it
again and again
but you're taking it again and again
right in front of all your senpais
so like you're taking their time and you
know the director is like um
uh we want it more like this way and
you're like okay
um and so yeah it's really
so nerve-wracking like yeah that's
that's like too that's like pressure on
top of pressure
like you're already pressured to be like
i'm gonna nail my line just so i can put
on a good performance like the teacher
going all right what's the answer or you
you you specifically
what is the answer to this math question
you don't know it come on you can do it
come on
come on
if you had like the director explain how
they want you to do the line differently
and you're like what
that does not make any sense uh yeah
when i was first like
in an anime um
one of the directors told me uh like in
japanese they said mochio
and yeah and i was like because i was
what does that mean
it's like like like soft like sword yeah
okay with like
like yeah so basically like play sword
yeah yeah yeah
sound more play sword fight yeah that's
so specific
yeah and i was like and and at that time
i was like i didn't know the word
it would be so awkward to ask the
director what does chamber mean right
yeah
so um i was like okay i'll try my best
and so i asked the person next to me
who was around the same age as me
and yeah she told me and and it still
didn't make any sense
[ __ ] does that mean yeah yeah and so
yeah
what does that mean like how did you how
to find out what he wanted
um i'm not sure
i've wondered what the tape should have
been but i got an okay so i guess
i was able to you know was that an okay
or was that like okay
it could be either one right yeah when
you're doing lines sometimes there's
that feeling of like you're not getting
it and you just you just
you know personally you're not going to
get it and then they're just like
i will just move on and i'm like no yeah
why
tell me yeah i get that feeling here
have you ever like said like a line and
that you you've just been like that was
that was an awful take and the
director's been like all right we're
moving on now
that's a good take yeah yeah had that a
lot okay
and that's why you should say like [ __ ]
at the end of my life right if i hated
it but then they would tell you to stop
saying [ __ ] because you're ruining the
line that they liked
you'd be like yeah [ __ ] because then you
couldn't use it
are you the type of voice actor that
watches the anime that they were in
after it like finishes and hairs and
everything so like you look back on
to kind of learn from yep because i
cannot do that really
like i hate hearing myself in voice
acting roles
because i get kind of second-hand
embarrassment from it being like because
i always i'm so harsh on myself all the
time so when i hear myself on like a
game or an anime i'm always like
i could have done that line like 10
times better
i know how you feel it's like that's
good though right like yeah you know
that you could improve yeah yeah yeah
it's good but it's also like
when people tell me being like oh i
heard you in the game then i'd be like
i don't know how i say on him so it's
like i can't even like talk about the
role that i was yeah
because i just don't know how it turned
out right because but there's a lot of
like big anime voice actors that are
like that as well
yeah yeah it's like i'm i mean like
hearing your own voice
after it's like because like you record
it and it's like several months after
you record it so obviously
like several months after you're kind of
like you've like brushed up on your
acting a little bit more than
you know what you had before so like
hearing it again it's like
oh like i didn't say that line properly
and like
i'm really strict on myself as well so
it's kind of like you know i look
like but then you know like it i think
it's really
important to like kind of look back yeah
yeah i think the thing that everyone
always says the most when they try and
start
voice acting is like they hate their own
voice and they can't stand it yeah
you have to like i've been i mean
personally i just think that if you
learn to like be able to listen to your
voice and not just
recoil and disgust you can then start
breaking it down and being like okay i
didn't do this that well right you can
start really focusing on that isn't it
that i'm okay with hearing my own voice
and youtube videos
it's just different just because because
you've heard it so many times when
you're acting you're
you're trying to do something like
you're trying to perform right yeah
youtube is just you yeah yeah i'm being
me i'm being an issue
i mean like i i feel though in in a lot
of my roles like because i'm not
trained or anything like that right i
just do it because i like it yeah and
i'm given the opportunity but like
the pop team epic one for instance yeah
i
i played i played a new york mate
yeah so dead ass if you watch like the
actual episode that aired
it's like the most aussie [ __ ] new
yorker it
york is just love the idea that you did
the take and the director was like it's
perfect yeah
you're like uh no please please please i
did it i did the first take
just thinking like you know we're gonna
kind of get like a gauge of like
how not good my new york accent is and i
actually gave up halfway
i tried to do like an american accent
but at that point especially i was like
my new york oh my american accent is not
that good where like
i can confidently act like i can
try and speak it casually but acting in
another accent is a completely different
set of skills
yeah so i was like i'm just gonna like
subtly turn it off like just turn the
gauge down as
the recording goes on so by the end of
it i was just like
yeah new york it's like the most
australian sound in new york
yeah i was i remember seeing that and i
was just like i feel like he's about to
drop the c bomb
that's an awesome you know when when's
it coming where's the coming
no but it was so funny because like i
thought for sure you know i would get
some pointers being like all right uh
you started off good but you kind of
depleted near the end let's do another
take
let's try that line again or something
like that fully expecting it the
director was like
all right you're good yeah but the door
didn't speak english right no
so he thought he thought i was like
perfect new york reactions like yeah
that's that's what all people from new
york sounds like i don't blame him
he doesn't know there's no way he'd know
right yeah exactly but then in japan
it's like um
you know when you when you go to
recordings it's like uh when you talk in
english it's like they expect you to
speak in an american accent but you know
because i'm from australia too so it's
like
yeah you never practice your american
accent when you're practicing
well yeah like i'm practicing now but
it's still really
hard to like i don't know like pronounce
all these
american english goes everything against
australia
yeah yeah i know i mean i can't do
americans we have to like contort our
faces
hard card a card hardened
in english like the tongue is like
towards the front of the mouth yeah
american english it's like flattering in
the back and that's like really hard to
do when you're british because you're
like why do i have to force my tongue
down you just sound like you're kind of
drowning half the time yeah i
i i you know mine sounds [ __ ] yeah i
barely can
i mean i'm much better at it now since
then because i practiced but
i mean i still couldn't confidently do
like an american english
role but i feel like i don't know just
from like watching anime recently
where like we are starting to get more
like english speaking roles done by
actual like native people yeah yeah
i feel like i've noticed like i think
finally
anime directors and producers are like
different accents in english exist
in japanese dubs or in japanese dubs
yeah but even in the english dubs as
well
because like a lot of the english dubs
are also overseen by like the original
directors and producers
so it's like i feel like they're finally
starting to realize like oh we can't
just get anyone who can speak
moderately good english like if we need
an american role
we need to get an american speaking
person yeah i i did an american
voice for a film the one that like uh
charlie critical is in oh
and it's like this like really raspy uh
deep like scary
voice like an american accent and then
they were like we wanted to do and i was
so i remember that we were
having i was having a call with the
people who were making this film
and they were telling me all about this
role and then this is going on for like
half an hour and they mentioned oh
um yeah he's american and then at the
end of it i was like so
like the accent i don't know if you
noticed i'm not american
so what do you want me to do and they're
like well he is american so could you do
american and i'm like i can
but it won't be good right yeah sorry i
did it i feel that your
american accent is probably better than
most right because i feel i don't know
when i do deep voices it's
easier because that the mouth shape is
easier but it's still [ __ ]
but i feel like you would laugh at me
but i feel like a lot of like british
actors for instance are usually
pretty good at nailing the american
accent there are so many british or just
like you know
actors not from america that you don't
know aren't from america until it's like
outed but
then you switch you swap to the other
way around with american
americans doing like british accents
yeah yeah yeah yeah because like how
many people
think you know like if they watch like
batman for instance right like
christian bale and gary oldman yeah not
america christian bale's welsh yeah
christian
right yeah gary oldman is very british
yeah so it's like it's just incredible
to think that like a lot of people just
don't know
like chris chris hemsworth as well it's
like christmas
they train british actors different to
americans yeah different ways of
learning acting so i think that has a
lot to do with it because like british
are more focused on like stage acting
right yeah learning training yeah being
more
classically trained yeah so it's a bit
different i don't know
yeah and i also feel like if you're
going to acting you kind of need to
learn how to do an american accent
that's because that's where most films
are made right you know that makes but
it's not the same the other way around
so you know
hating american accents for stuff you
always have to do it for things it sucks
i hate it
just let me use my british accent just
give me like an australian character
i've never seen an australian character
the one time where i was like oh i might
have a chance is like uh what was the
the free uh like what was it the movie
oh like
season 2 was it was based
in sydney yeah it was and so i
yeah but they hired non-australian
actors an accident like actresses so i'm
like
yeah i'm right here i'm right here right
here
right here what is it just hit up that
[ __ ] school
yes go through the contact list
what do you think of the bad engrish in
anime um
well uh you know i know people who
who've been asked to like
talk in english when they're not like
you know that it's the director just
like you should
do it yeah they're kind of like um well
they're like try your best but you know
like you know
and obviously the actors are trying
their best yeah yeah it's like
i just feel like it's an unfortunate
situation yeah yeah it's just kind of
like oh
i guess they had to but yeah yeah like a
lot of my friends like ask me how to
pronounce stuff because they're like
i don't know how like you know they
pronounce this sentence and
stuff like that so yeah i think it's
really hard for them to like
you know pronounce something that
they're not used to pronouncing do they
ever worry about how it's perceived by
like foreign fans
uh yeah they do they're like you know i
i tried my best but
it's like i don't think it sounds like
native and then
you know feel bad laughing at the
crocodile
but everyone's japanese like yeah it's
it's a trip
well i mean it's like the english and
like devilman crybaby as well right yeah
oh yeah yeah yeah
and i had to i have to do alfredo next
to that guy oh really yeah
oh yeah yeah and it's like yeah i mean
like i mean
it's it's it's not a no one wins yeah oh
yeah no one wins exactly i mean like
his english was probably the most decent
out of like all the other actors but
like
yeah i had the exact same thing like
during break like all the actors were
coming up to me being like how do you
pronounce this
how do i make this sound as fluent and
like naturally speaking as possible and
i'm just like
dude you're asking the wrong person this
is said in new york
why are you asking me like i'm
struggling to say the word just say that
that's what everyone says that's the
meme
just give them a copy of like every man
scorsese yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah jesus have you ever been recognized
in japan for your voice work
like someone spot on the street is like
oh my god i know you oh
i haven't had that before but i've had
someone ask me like at a cafe
yeah like when i was checking out i've
had someone ask me if i was a voice
actor
and or just randomly yeah just randomly
they could just feel the voice acting
aura from you
i don't know yeah and so like it was
like a
young male guy and he was like yeah
like like do you by any chance do voice
acting and i'm like
is that like a pickup line in japan bro
that voice got me acting um
yeah i'm about to sip at your voice
[Laughter]
says one word my queen i will simp for
you
did you go to the checkout and say like
in a voice-acting way or did you start
or real care like maybe did i
did like the anime reaction lines like
you can have a point guard
so like for like everyone watching who
maybe want
aspires to be a voice actor or actress
oh yeah
what what do you think it takes to be
one professionally in japan
i think it's like obviously you need
like your acting skills
but i think it's more like being able to
communicate with the people around you
and like um yeah like like you know like
because if you have a manager then you
have
like you have to be in good
relationships with your manager because
they're the ones picking
who to you know push forward for the
audition and stuff like that right
and um you know you'll have to be like
doing good with you know the
the voice actors around you and your
senpai's and
yeah i think it's all just social yeah
yeah yeah how it always is though like
the entertainment industry is always who
you know and who you're friends with
right it's been
i feel that's just like but i feel
especially like that on top of
how already socially politically like
you know
charged i guess japan is just yeah
yeah like i'm always like you know
because like you know
even with like towards your senpai right
you have to you want to be like
if you want to become good friends with
like that person like
you know like it's just so hard to
decide how
like polite you have to be towards them
right
because you don't want to seem like a
kiss off yeah yeah yeah because it's
like it's
it's that [ __ ] rolling dice
about to say it's like it's that real
fine line between
you know showing that you respect your
senpai yeah
but also not kissing their butt yeah
yeah and obviously because like you know
in japanese if you're too polite it's
like
you know
so that's really hard like was that
something you just had to learn on the
job i'm guessing right
yeah it was really because i guess like
moving from australia to here like the
social
dynamics is just so different from like
from
moving to australian like a more like
i'd say like western kind of mentality
to japan which is like
very very you know very very different
very very i don't know what the word i'm
looking for here
it's like you know if japan is kind of
like a pyramid scheme
australia australia is just like do you
mean just a pyramid you just did it
if
it's the social multi-level marketing
that we're selling here
if if japan socially is like a pyramid
hierarchy that's
like a hierarchy yeah right that's the
one we're looking for
a pyramid and then australia is just
everyone's kind of on the fly
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it's like you
refer to your boss by your name whereas
like if you did that in japan
instantly yeah yeah
or would it be a power move
can they just be like what's up to the
director oh like some people are like
like the legends they're like yeah yeah
i feel though that takes
place yeah yeah yeah yeah because there
seems to be so much
i mean like voice actors here like very
very like famous ones
seen as like almost like gods they're
like the top celebrities
right right i wonder if that like you
know in the
work environment it kind of means they
could just rock up and be like yo i own
this place
i'm sure some of them you know like with
that much you know like fame and power
like i'm sure some people get cocky a
little bit because one thing i noticed
i was looking on on twitter right and
the
voice actor for jonno and has like 1.2
million followers on twitter
and i'm like holy [ __ ] that's like and
it's it's japanese
yeah so the market is only really japan
and i guess people like jojo but like
that's a
that is a lot of fun like one million in
japan is the equivalent of like 10
million
yeah yeah it's insane yeah like yeah
that's which blew my mind i was like
how many yeah i like all of the i feel
like most of the
top top voice actors in japan have like
that kind of a lot
yeah yeah does there's a you know being
popular on social media or being popular
on tv does that does that help you get a
lot of roles in japan is that like a
factor
yes it it helps like yeah because you
know like if you have more followers
then
like you can you know what is it like
add
not really advertise more but it's like
you know people know you so it's like
yeah you know like so they're more
inclined to like watch them yeah yeah so
there's
a lot of voice like this in japan that
like hey guys getting into tick tock now
um yeah there are some voice actors who
do tick tock and like you know um a lot
more voice actors now
are doing like youtube as well right
right yeah that's kind of the same in
english like
the voice like because you kind of have
to have social media presence
unfortunately
yeah like the voice actor who uh did uh
gin talkie
like he's huge on twitter like he's like
he means the [ __ ] out of himself
a lot of people like especially in the
west just know him
everyone loves them with memes yeah
exactly yeah one thing i'm sure that the
audience is slightly curious about um
and
you know people who watch anime they
want to be a voice center in japan
that's the thing right
have you ever seen someone who wasn't
native in japan was it native and
japanese like make it as a voice actor
is that like a thing
because i've heard often people who have
tried but i haven't heard anyone who's
managed to do it who like wasn't
native or born in japan because i've
heard that again they are so
strict on all the pronunciation and the
way that you talk that you do have to be
native
oh i personally haven't seen
anyone right rip weebs
[Laughter]
i feel just like bilingual voice actors
is just
not a market that has been filled yet
yeah i can't really think of like a
notable voice actor in japan or in the
west that
can do a role like that that is not in
their native language
it's really hard because you know like
for like voice acting especially in
japan
like you have to be able to act like and
speak in japanese really fluently but
you also have to have that like
japanese you know bowing and yeah
you know social skills as well so i
think because when i first came to japan
i was really like
shocked by all the stuff that you have
to do and
so i think yeah there's so many stuff
you need to do other than
you know um being able to act in
japanese
and now you have to like dance and sing
and
all these other stuff that you need to
do so it's like yeah i mean and
you've already said that you started off
like very young pursuing the stream as
well
so you're like really determined from a
young age so yeah i guess it takes a lot
of work
now rising grind and like there is like
um it's like it's a pretty harsh world
so it's like
you know um you have to get used to
people saying harsh stuff to you if that
makes sense
like you know oh don't worry we've been
there yeah we've talked about this a lot
yeah yeah
it's like yeah and um obviously because
you know there's people on the internet
as well but there's
you know um the people around you like
you know
um you know saying like this you need to
work on this you need to work on that
and this
part of like your acting or this part of
you you need to fix and stuff like that
so
yeah it's good though being able to
criticism right obviously
someone who's higher up and they know
what they're talking about that's true
invaluable right to get someone you like
your [ __ ] but
you can get better yeah let me tell you
how yeah pyramid
trade but i know um like because
when you go to school the voice acting
school in japan it's like
um the teachers there like some teachers
are really really strict so like i know
some students who used to go there but
because the teachers were like
too strict they i didn't think they they
were able to
take it mentally yeah and um they kind
of like
you know started not coming to school
and stuff like that so yeah it's
definitely not a
job for everyone trial by fire by fire
right yeah
in such a competitive industry it's
bound to happen yeah yeah especially in
the entertainment industry as well i'm
sure
i'm sure there's a lot of stories that
we will never hear
yeah yeah like if you suck you suck you
know that's all it is
i am curious as a professional voice
actress who's like been in the field
what do you think of
the v tubing scene that's just like
popped up in the last year and a bit oh
well i think it's pretty cool because
you know um
i haven't really like um done youtubing
before yeah
but um you know because you use your
voice and you're kind of like
playing a character yeah a lot of people
are just playing an anime character but
just like they're just never they'd
never break character or like like try
to stay in character
as much as possible right so it's like
like you're
acting as like a character on youtube
but it's not the real you so you have to
kind of like
you know i think it's really cool
because you have to think so much about
the character and like
how that character would act if
something happens you know
yeah is that something you've ever like
thought about getting into it all or
trying out
um not really but
i think it'll be fine if i was able to
try doing youtubing
because i feel like v tubing is such a
weird line between like
acting as a character but also like a
lot of youtubers also put
themselves into the role yeah as well
and kind of break character yeah
so i feel it's just like another set of
skills why build a character when you
already are one right like just
just use your personality yeah yeah
exactly spoken like a true person
what can i say you know what you'd be a
great animal of youtuber
just just just like don't be like don't
be a cat girl just be a cat
just like just like make animal noises
there is a v tuber actually that is just
straight up a dog
really really yeah like it's just like a
shimano
but they're speaking like a human okay
yeah it's like
a gorilla
[Laughter]
you know you don't need to either
animator you've already done that before
yeah yeah someone gives you ten dollars
just
meow louder no because like i feel
uh because i feel like there's a lot of
i don't know like do you
see a lot of people in your field doing
v tubing or is it like
is it something that has just been so
new that no one's really known how to
like deal with it yet
oh it's it's pretty new so i don't don't
really know anyone around me who's like
done youtubing before right but like
yeah because it's becoming really
like huge right yeah there's like so
many like youtubers on youtube i think
you know there will be like a day when
when when
yeah professional voice actors
i feel though it's like maybe it might
just be like a completely different
category right it's like i feel a lot of
like the professional voice actors who
have like made it in the industry yeah
probably think like oh i don't really
need to go down there because i got you
know
right whereas like youtubers are like
kind of a lot of them i feel are
aspiring voice actors
who just want to build up a cv yeah you
know i'm like i can do voices i can
i can voice act all that kind of stuff
so yeah i feel like going from v tubing
to professional voice acting
might be a viable option but i feel the
other way around might not
really happen i don't know maybe
i don't know but like i know like like
you know
like acting for games and anime is
really different to acting for like
youtubing so it's like yeah i don't know
you're not on script
have you ever been star struck when you
when you're on the job
what do you mean by starstruck i know
just as in like you
did enough article with like a voice
actor or actress that you
just loved before yeah like who's the
most like
whoa person you've ever met um
whoa really yeah that's [ __ ] cool
yeah
i need a little context too old scar is
like
yeah a snake he did salt snakes oh okay
wow
like he's the kind he's the guy that he
has that really distinct like
talking style where he's like yeah i
can't i can't do an impression
oh my god he he's kind of like the
tournament yeah yeah it's it's like
yeah yeah yeah actually does a really
good like old stocking
yeah yeah yeah he's just you know like
the soul of snakes yeah yeah yeah yeah
like
but he's probably like the top [ __ ] yeah
like he's like a [ __ ] legend
yeah yeah does he mean a lot on twitter
i follow him on twitter so i don't know
i feel like he does right
no i know i know the english voice stuff
david david hater i know david hayes
[Laughter]
yeah again like i feel the biggest like
mimas are usually the ones that are kind
of like the legends
but i feel like even within the legends
a lot of them you know take their
stuff like very very seriously like you
know the voice for like luffy for
example is like yeah you never see her
like meaning or anything like that yeah
yeah you know the voice for gintoki is
like [ __ ]
whatever he's just like playing his
character right he's literally gin
talking in real life
how do you stay composed when you walk
in the room with
it was so um like nerve-wracking because
i don't know because i i've like i've
seen him in like
magazines and like you know i've read
his books and like
it was just did you play it cool you i
tried
i don't know if i was able to yeah but
um there was like all these other like
voice actors as well who were like
really big right yeah so
it's just i don't know for me it was
really hard to like
act um in front of them yeah yeah yeah
because you know they're like super
super good
yeah you're like you know like you just
came into the industry and you're like
the bottom of the rack
hierarchy yeah pyramid scheme
have you guys ever been star struck by
like anyone i think we've talked about
this probably for me it was like
hiroyuki stamina i think i've already
told the story
yeah have you ever gone that was like a
youtuber
like someone in the same field as you i
don't think so
no yeah i think no i don't know like
after you do it for a while you're just
kind of like
[ __ ] so boring you're all so boring i
just
sit inside i would be lying if i said i
wasn't like that with felix the first
time yeah
yeah of course i mean like for me
youtubers i view
youtubers as just like people i want to
hang out with yeah
you know because like we all do the same
thing at the end of the day right i feel
like once you get past
a certain like level it or you kind of
get
a certain a certain rank in the
hierarchy you can't like all youtubers
kind of like get each other you know
because we all go
we all got to go through like the same
[ __ ] are you a big consumer of youtube
content
uh yeah i watch a lot of youtube really
in english
in english and japanese well you have a
youtube channel right yeah i have a
youtube channel too yeah yeah
wait no i think i did watch one really
yeah yeah i watched like your
introduction video on my youtube channel
i'm like wow this chick is
very aussie holy [ __ ]
did you do a video where you did a test
to see how aussie you were
oh yeah i did with the slang yeah yeah
because i'm not really fond of like
australian slang i don't know it's
terrible
arvo
so that's how we know it i don't know
why aussies end everything with o i like
because
it's it's just rolls off the tongue like
i've never used um
bottle o you know you never use bottles
i've never used bottle o before
because like you're you're that's a
liquor store you're just adding you're
just adding a syllable to a word that
doesn't need a syllable added to it yeah
i don't know yeah
but like bottle oh i feel was like who
the [ __ ] came up with that it's a word
let me end a word that ends in a verb in
a vowel
with another vowel so non-native
speakers bolo
is the slang for bottle right no no no
no
you just thought it was a bottle this
whole time i thought it was just a
bottle this whole time jerry says
i'm just like what the [ __ ] are you
talking about not long enough apparently
if you say like i'm just popping okay
okay i probably for even name speakers
we get [ __ ] confused
as well it's like oh i'm just gonna pop
over to the bottle
it means i'm gonna go buy some alcohol
at the liquor store liquor stores
sorry americans we we've heard youtubers
yeah sorry yeah
maybe we've been too harsh on you so
what are your what are some of your
favorite youtube channels um
i watch uh a youtube channel called
jolly
yeah i think you mentioned that earlier
right yeah yeah yeah and
um um i i watch a lot of um
animal videos on youtube like
give us a taste give us a taste i wanna
get a better feel of your character
i watch um my favorite dog is called a
samoyed
it's like a huge white dog what's what's
the youtube chat what's it about
um the the channel is called um milky
bulky tan
and it's like a youtube channel um that
has a
summery dog and two cats
and um it's just them living their life
you just watch that
it's a slice it's an animal slice of
life yeah yes
and um it's it's funny because for like
animal youtube
videos like the the owners are called
butlers
they're called butlers because they take
care of them i didn't know that
oh wow yeah so like animal youtube
terminology
yeah how do they ask you to like
subscribe and smash the like button
um on the screen
[Laughter]
so you mainly watch animal videos uh
yeah immediately watch animal videos
damn
there is there is one animal channel
actually that i watch quite often
it's this like korean channel i think
that uh it's this guy who has like a pet
i think it's a guinea pig um but he
makes
miniature models for oh i've seen this
one right oh really so like he uses like
he uses like arts and crafts like
cardboard and stuff like that and he
made like an
onsen for his sound booth for his guinea
pig just like puts the guinea pig in and
just like
sees what the guinea pig does cute as
hell
actually no i did get into like there
was like there's like ant
uh and youtubers you've seen them oh
those those [ __ ]
okay they those those are good they're
basically yeah he starts off with like
all right well he's just got a tank full
of ants and then like the next video
will be like
i have con made a giant castle network
of ants
and this whole like living room will be
like tunnels
of ants it's crazy was that the guy who
was like who fed the baby cockroach
yeah and like the as it's getting eaten
alive by ants and it's got like 100
million views or something and i'm just
like
i can't watch insects i just think of
like what happens if one of these breaks
yeah yeah yeah i'm constantly thinking
the house it must be like quarantined
off like burn it down
like it's just it's it's literally a
killer with fire kind of situation right
you just got to [ __ ]
how do you bring like a girl into that
house right
oh yeah my bedroom's just past the ants
line
i know there's one that like reviews
like rat traps
that's a whole channel what i actually
kind of like why am i saying one of
course
it's like a whole channel where the dude
just reviews rat traps that's it
he like shows that what makes a good rat
trap well you should watch the youtube
channel right
this is a question now you're going to
be curious what types of rat traps
i think he has like over like 500 videos
on like different rat tracks
oh wow yeah of course [ __ ] melon
knows it
like yeah my favorite this guy will make
some insane trap and in the end the one
that works best is always just like a
ramp that goes into a bucket
that's just like the one that always
works best anyways i'm getting off topic
but
there i there's some there is a weird
category that er anything you want on on
youtube someone just doesn't exist as a
youtube channel
but you make your own youtube videos
right yes i do do you do it often
what's your channel called first so
people can check it out it's called uh
shoottube
for anyone who wants to be on screen
right now yep yeah go subscribe
yes please
[Laughter]
down in the description what type of
content do you normally do um i usually
uh talk in english
and i just i don't know i just make
stuff about
english and japanese food
like cultural cultural differences and
stuff like that culture stuff
yeah culture stuff right do you like
bring like the australian side a lot or
it's kind of every now and then i think
yeah i think i do yeah what made you
want to start it
you've been all day yeah oh my gosh i'm
sorry i think i just saw the life
like in between our eyes right there
why did i
i heard that question
why did you start start
i don't know just because you wanted to
just because you wanted to just wanted
to because
all the cool kids are starting i'm
interrogating i'm like you think you're
ready kid huh
you're a voice actress no let's see
let's see you become a youtuber then
okay
yeah so if people want to go check out
the youtube channel it's in the
description so go check it out yes
please
yeah yeah now you should make a video
being like the truth about trash tape
just like these easy million views
expo trash taste expose my experience on
trash taste
i can't believe there was such a nice
guy yeah
and you see just that's what makes this
held up you see this
off screen and you're just like what
what am i supposed to do with this
mailing what am i
what am i supposed to do it's just
incest there's three [ __ ] exclamation
points
like it's a [ __ ] quick time event
well i heard someone was doing like a a
sponsor or something and it was a live
event
apparently someone was holding up like
cards telling them to do reactions and
apparently the words they wrote on the
card were just like nonsensical and they
just didn't know what they meant i can
just imagine being confused
trying to promote a bike and they're
like dry you're like
what should i stay with him do i try it
the bike drives it dries
very fast when you were describing your
experience about how when you like flub
up a line you just gotta like stay
silent and just walk back
right i really hope that you don't see
when we need to record like a
sponsorship segment
because that's trying to like read a
script it's just like a [ __ ] bomb
going off
it's it's an absolute mess it's like
it's like for some reason i don't know
what it is but the moment we get past
the script it's like
you must learn english from scratch once
again you are not native in this
language
true especially yeah i'm the worst
our sponsors take twice as long as they
should because just like having a mental
breakdown halfway through so i can't do
it
um so i'm just having a guess but i'm
guessing that you like anime
right yes it was just like a feeling
just like i just got that vibe i don't
know where i got it from
um so what kind of anime do you like um
ah i watch
a lot of anime uh i like really name
every anime
[Laughter]
oh you're an anime fan oh i like creamy
mommy
wow um that's not the first show
that i would have expected coming from
your mouth i really like creamy mummy um
what's creamy mummy it's like there's a
girl called mummy
right and it's just creamy yeah she's
really she held a creamy dog
very unfortunate name in english that's
what i was thinking of getting right
unfortunately
i think it was aired in like the 1980s
or something
yeah that's your favorite yeah wow um
recent animes i watch uh boku no hero
academia
of course of course
[Laughter]
airing this spring
[Music]
two not yet okay
we'll leave it up happen how do you feel
about it
i i know i i can already tell that you
watch quite a fair bit
considering the fact that not only was
your first choice creamy mummy but
also the fact that you brought a milder
penguin drone yeah yeah like
psychopaths as well yeah i love cycle
yeah i just kept nodding with that
penguin while i'm like yeah
what is that like this modern penguin
drum is like oh god can you explain that
it's really hard it's such a weird show
yeah yeah you've definitely seen clips
of it though probably yeah yeah yeah
it's got a lot of animals yeah it's got
a lot makes a lot of sense
i think i'm seeing a theme here do you
like
b stars
i
oh my animals well it's like what were
some of the anime that were like the
biggest influences for you to
like be a voice actress when you were a
kid um i think bleach
was leech wow wow i mean um yeah because
obviously like hitsuka was
voiced by a lady and um
all the actors were like you know like
like
so like i mean they were cool as [ __ ]
we've said a lot about bleach but uh i
mean everything about it was
cool you know especially he's a guy
right like romy park is such an amazing
voice yeah yeah yeah
you know like especially like i think
she did alphonse as well right
oh yeah no no she did um edward oh she
did yeah yeah yeah yeah
i would know that yeah yeah and she's
hanji from um
attack on titus that's right oh yeah
that's it yeah yeah she's like
wow like yeah did you like when when you
were trying to get into
the voice acting field or like how much
how much research did you do with like
fellow voice actresses in the field or
like
fellow like voice actors oh as in like
what kind of research like just like
looking into it right because i
like i know there are some fans out
there uh in the anime field who like
really really into like the voice actors
and voice actresses right
were you like that as well were you like
yeah okay
say you will talk yeah yeah yes i'll say
your talking though like i had like
posters of voice actors on my wall
and i'll have like them as my back like
as my wallet
yeah and so like um i would like search
like you know who voiced like who like i
would be like when i watch an anime i'll
always watch the credits
yeah i'll be like oh like you know this
was voiced by this like
this voice actor and i'm like and so
like yeah did you ever like have
did you ever sit through an anime just
because of
like a particular voice actor was in it
ah yeah yeah
yeah i feel because like i have a couple
of friends will like see your attackers
as well and they're like
they can hear like half a second of a
phrase and they're immediately like yeah
that's that one
yeah yeah yeah you instantly know it
yeah did you ever get to the point where
you bought like
uh like voice cds oh yeah oh my gosh
what's this it's like
um there's a lot of like different kinds
of voice cds
um out in the world um and there's like
like there's like voice dramas and
there's also ones where they kind of
like
talk to you talk to you it's like it's
like
think of a think of an and a
podcast except you're doing the podcast
with them and it's in like pov
yeah yeah yeah this is this because
you're part of trash
it's like an asmr thing on youtube now
so i guess they made it yeah yeah
yeah and um they use like but they act
as those characters yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah they also have um like
they have these microphones
um yeah and it's kind of like it's
shaped like a person's face
uh the binaural yeah yeah and then they
use that to take
um some of the audio so it's like um
sometimes you hear the audio from the
right side
and it kind of seems like they're there
oh it's like the asmr
yeah yeah yeah yeah norman made a mic
and it's literally like a foam head
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it's super
[ __ ] expensive
yeah it's really [ __ ] weird yeah
but it's like but it's yeah so for i
think decades now these like voice
actors do these like drama cds where
they were like
for example like you know romy park
would do one of his
and if it's like if his again was like
hanging out with you
like if you were on a date with this
particular character and they were like
they would play out these scenarios in
pov
all right if you were in that position
and like people would just like listen
to it
yeah i mean i've seen like some of the
short anime
that have that i kind of like that where
it's just like pov you have a girlfriend
it's just like every episode there's
like a different girl literally
dora the explorer because like i've seen
some where they're like they would say a
line and then they kind of pause for a
couple of years
waiting for your response i think i
remember i love
you when i won't finish kogi i'll say i
need more code geass yeah like the story
continues
in an audio cd yeah yeah yeah yeah like
a voice i got it and you sound like a
museum tour
you know what i mean and i was like what
is this i can't listen to this
like welcome to britannia it's like
britannia was once here
i've actually only bought one audio cd
my entire time of being an anime fan
what was it
no it was like an audio drama so like
like it was it was because like it ended
and i'm just like
i need more i i the manga is not doing
it for me i need to hear the voice
actors and actresses
playing out the ending of this that's
why i [ __ ] bought it and it's the
only audio drama i've bought so far
and i don't regret anything it was
amazing i think the closest i ever got
to that was i used to tune in because
like a lot of voice actors especially
like the top ones
do like radio shows yeah they do
like talking about their role in the
anime of like you know if they like work
together
or whatever they would you know go for
like however long the anime stands for
basically so like the closest i ever got
to that was i used to like tune in every
week to
kajiyuki and shimonohiro like attack on
titan
radio and it was really cool because
like they would openly just like
kind of poke fun up the show a lot of
times a lot but it's also like i mean
yeah you guys are the voices of the show
so i guess that gives you like some
credit to be like
that was kind of ridiculous wasn't it
this is still a big thing in japan the
audio
cds it is i think it's getting bigger
now like
because it's easier to yeah sell right
yeah
and i mean like like we just established
it's more about
building yourself up as like a kind of
like an idol in some cases right
is there like anything i mean how long
how many years have you been doing voice
acting now like professionally
uh five years now
because i debuted in 2016.
right five years now five years now is
there any like voice role or like type
of character that you haven't done yet
that you
really really want to do like i want to
do like a tsundere or i want to do like
a maid or like just you know any like
archetypes that you want to do
i want to try like a a boy
yeah because i guess that's the romy
pocket yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's a guy right
i mean like a lot of like kind of
younger boy characters
are voiced by females yeah yeah they are
yeah because you know people keep
forgetting that like ash or like
naruto are voiced by females and luffy
as well yeah or goku kids are expensive
kids normally don't have proper voice
acting like training you're taking
directions
oh my god goku was voiced by like a
young boy and he just like [ __ ] has a
tasty ball playing halfway through a
comment
we need more voice cracks in anime
that's what we need more realistic
representations of puberty
hell yeah have you ever done any events
where you meet your fans or anything
like that
um yes i have um i i'm in this uh
like a uh vocal dance unit called
primaporta
okay and um uh we had like this thing
called watashike where we
like hand the cds to uh the
people who bought the cds right and um
yeah we were able to like talk to
um the fans um for like 30 seconds a
minute
right now there's a speed run there yeah
really sweetie
but yeah yeah is it kind of like the
same thing as in like with like
i know a lot of the water sky with like
idols for instance that's the
handshaking event yeah but
the time extends depending on how many
cds you bought oh we
didn't have that it was kind of like um
hierarchy yeah
did you have to do a handshaking thing
as well oh no we didn't do hatching it
was more like
um waving and just talking like
you know waving in close proximity well
i saw videos of like guys
not letting go and like security oh yeah
i guess
it's so scary yeah definitely is it is
it weird like when the first time that
you had to do that
is it a weird feeling to be like wow
these people came for me
yeah it feels really like because
because you know like
like on the internet like sns like you
don't know how many people are actually
like
into you like i mean they might comment
and stuff like that but you don't know
like if they're really really like you
know
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and
then so when you actually go
and like meet people and they're like oh
my gosh i've been wanting to meet you
for like so long you like you're like
i'm so glad i did this job
i'm glad to find my parents yeah it
makes it all worth it
yeah it does feel like wow somebody
cares yeah yeah yeah
it's just like being able to meet all
those people and
um even if you can't like talk to
everyone just seeing them
and like you know when you're like when
you attend events and stuff and they're
like calling out your name it's like
like like you know you feel really happy
so like for me you're doing it
yeah for me yeah yeah oh my gosh you're
the best mate yeah
in my life
that's not so fun do you go too many
events then now i imagine it's
yeah yeah yeah but um yeah i
like before like this all happened like
yeah i used to like attend events pretty
often
and have you been on the other side like
like uh
yes i actually have like before going
into this industry like
um i'll buy tickets to like concerts
yeah
lives and i'll be like buy the cds i'll
buy the cds and i'll buy the goods
yeah he waved at me
it'd be really awkward if you turn up to
the voice session they'd be like why do
i know you
it was funny because one time i went to
like a um
concert and um it was like a female
voice actors concert
and like her fans were like mostly male
but i really liked her so like i went
there by myself
and um all the fans were like male right
so like it'll be like one girl and all
these males and
because i think they thought that it was
really rare that a girl would
come to that concert they were kind of
like um
to me like oh if i get too like noisy
using like
the blades like please let me know like
let me put away
i felt the exact same way when i went to
the the sailor moon museum
oh like because it was like like five
years ago
in the mori arts museum yeah um and they
had a sailor
moon museum and i was like i [ __ ]
love sailor moon
imagine a room full of just like tiny
like
japanese girls like falling over sailor
moon meanwhile in the middle of it
there's this massive
white dude just being like that's so
[ __ ] cute
oh my god dude i [ __ ] love mercury
i felt i've never had so many women
stare at me for all the whole problem
this is the weirdest experience of my
life
looking at
yeah but uh is there any like kind of
social media that you want to shout out
like i guess your youtube channel
anything you want to shout out to the
audience um
i have a twitter account uh if
people want to follow it they will [ __ ]
just follow it follow
follow follow we'll do it for you
also uh shu's youtube channel
what else do you have um that's all i
have that's it yes no tick-tock
no tick-tock no how do you how do you do
the trendy dancers
yeah actually tick-tock would be like
the perfect platform to show off all
your skills that you literally trained
years for
like your singing skills where you
literally had to hide your
heart from your mum yeah your voice
acting skills yeah you can literally do
that i don't take talk
follow twitter yeah go buy her drama cds
pov you are a princess and listen to her
in
your favorite anime yeah yes please and
games
and games and everything and everything
yes yeah check out her stuff
but uh in the meantime you can check out
the lovely patrons who are just
them on screen right now oh my god yeah
who's your favorite patreon shoe is it
that one
that one point somewhere on the screen
what what they'll be watching this one
i like that dropping at the mouth
but yeah if you like to support the show
then make sure to head on over to our
patreon patreon.com also follow us on
twitter send us your memes on the
subreddit and if you hate our faces
listen to us on
spotify but uh yeah thanks for coming
sure thank you for inviting me it was
really fun
i hope you had fun it was really fun
even through some of the
dodgy words that we use or whatever
shoes manager is just like sweating i'm
sorry you had to see this off screen
uh that was like a badge we can hold on
to that
for any like emergency situations we can
just like us
if there's a situation i'll just be like
[Laughter]
one day one day mainland's gonna be like
guys i have the perfect
perfect thing to show
we'll keep it for the next hentai
episode but uh yeah hopefully you guys
enjoyed this episode and we'll see you
guys next one
[Music]
you